[Music]
democrats plan to pay for much of their
next spending package by raising the tax
burden on corporations in the united
states their proposal would increase the
corporate tax rate from 21 percent to as
much as 28
and reform the tax treatment of foreign
profits of u.s multinational
corporations while raising the corporate
tax rate could generate significant
revenue for the federal government it
would reduce the competitiveness of u.s
corporations and burden working-class
americans a superior policy one without
the adverse economic consequences of a
corporate tax hike is a carbon tax a
carbon tax will raise energy prices to
reflect the environmental damage
emissions cause and as consumers and
producers work to avoid the tax
emissions will fall a modest 15 per ton
carbon tax would raise as much revenue
as president biden's corporate rate
proposal moreover it would drive
advancements and new investments in the
energy and transportation sectors
and it would negate the need for costly
and inefficient clean energy tax credits
or regulations like democrats clean
electricity standards
do you think congress should address the
risks of climate change and impose a
price on carbon instead of raising the
corporate tax rate
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from aei